hi guys John boyega here I play Jaeger
pilot Jack Pentecost in my new movie
Pacific Rim uprising Pacific Rim has
some of the most creative fans in the
world
your passion has inspired us every day
to make sure this new film delivers all
the crazy awesomeness you guys deserve
so to say thank you I'm excited to
announce that we are looking for two
Pacific Rim super fans to become a part
of movie in Pacific Rim uprising we
reveal the Chateau domes Hall of Heroes
a memorial that shows Holograms of all
the greatest Jaeger pilots throughout
the history of the kaiju war this is
your chance to become a part that line
up on screen alongside Pacific rooms
most legendary heroes how are we gonna
find the biggest Pacific Rim super fans
well you're gonna show us share your
fandom and it can be anything
Jaeger cosplay fan videos kaiju body are
stories music tattoos whatever the show
us how Pacific Rim has inspired you tell
us your story and you get the chance to
become a part of us we can't wait to see
what you're going to come up with visit
go Jaeger comm for more information and
I'll see you in the drift
you